Kim Jong-un can never exist without Chinese communist party sponsorship.
There's no way he can be dictated right now.
And he's improving 25 millions of people and the United nations,
they are saying only resemblance.
We can see what's happening to North Korean people is a Holocaust.
That's what cause it happening again,
North Korea and the words denying your game and the mainstream, of course,
Hollywood and media, because they don't want to like upset China.
[Inaudible].
How were you sort of welcomed into inter the Western world after
this? I mean, now you live in Chicago now you're your friends.
We have a ton of similar friends that are, that are all fighting these battles,
but, but you've lived through this battle. How did,
how did you go from just sort of activism in South Korea to,
to where you are now?
Yeah, in South Korea, unfortunately I was heavily,
heavily discriminated and I couldn't feed in.
I had to lie to people that I was South Korean because they were so many
things like South Koreans who were discriminated against for North Koreans.
And that's why I chose to come to America.
Even the people who say this is like racist country.
This is a congestion where most embracing included in my life.
So I chose ESS my home because it's like,
there's no racism for me here to experience. Right.
So before we get to the non racism of the United States, so,
so South Koreans were discriminating against North Koreans. Was that,
was that simply because they didn't know North Koreans or they felt that too
many North Koreans were coming over or what, what is that?
Because you don't really think that there would be that type of discrimination.
Just because we are coming from a poor country and, you know, South Koreans,
uh, they discriminate against like Southeast Asians like that.
NAMI's Thailand in PI Filipinos and North Korea is also a poor country.
I don't think they discriminate people as much when they come from France or
Europe or Western Europe or like USA,
but without when people coming from poor country. So we,
even though we were saying people, when I went to South Korea,
they were just making fun of my accent because I was speaking with Northern
accent and, you know, they were asking me like, I used by,
why are you talking to me? And it's like, if I were spy,
why would I even escape? So it was very tough.
Right? So what put you on my radar was a few months ago,
a whole bunch of people started sending me a video of you talking about your,
your adventure and your journey and everything else.
And you happen to mention that you read don't burn this book and that it helped
you in some way,
which is I don't even have the words to explain my gratitude for
that. I mean, it's,
it's just beyond imagination considering what you've lived through.
But in essence, you are now here in the United States.
Do you consider yourself an activist first?
Like what do you consider yourself now? Really? You're,
you're an author obviously. And you're out there fighting all these battles,
but what, what do you consider yourself now?
Because I'm a fighter and trying to fight against North Korea,
dictatorship and Chinese communist party that sponsors dictator should be North
Korea. And I think that's why I began. I mean, on chair,
I read your book and it was, uh, I was more trying to be,
you know what? I tried to do my best to raise awareness.
And at Hollywood, everybody, they don't pick up North Korean story.
Like they talk about slavery and they talk about like Malala,
who was shot by Taliban.
They talk about was captured by ISIS and Michelle Obama with the standing of
alcohol anchors, all these people in the mainstream,
standing up for a lot of girls and like human trafficking issues.
But nobody here in like West wants to talk about North Korea because
that offsets Chinese region.
Is it? Yeah. Is that crazy for you?
Like you come here and you see this sort of fear around
talking, not, not just about North Korea, but we talked about this a little,
a little bit, a couple of weeks ago, just that you see the way we,
we are afraid of speaking up here in the freest country,
in the world about whatever it might be.
Yeah. I mean, that's like, that's so shocking to me.
Like I thought America was like land of the free, the home of the brave way.
That's like how I thought of this country to be in coming here.
And like the movies,
when they make a one North Korea to expulsion the dictatorship,
the Hallyu like drop the sponsorship.
And there's no way I can like talk about it because there's Kim Jong-un can
never exist without Chinese comments, parts of sponsorship.
There's no way he can be dictated right now.
And he's improving 25 millions of people and the United nations,
they are saying only resemblance.
We can see what's happening to North Korean people is a Holocaust.
That's what cause it happening again,
North Korea and the words denying your game and the mainstream, of course,
Hollywood and media, because they don't want to like upset China.
Yeah. I mean, is it that obvious? Like, it's that they just,
Hollywood just wants Chinese dollars. The last transformers movie, you know,
they really want it to push to China.
So they fill in part of it there and they put all the products and all that kind
of stuff. I mean, is it really that simple?
It just comes down to money and they see a new market there and that's it.
So that's like what? I only recall.
I discovered last few years that I've been, keep trying to talk to people.
And then as soon as I talk about the, my spoon, China is being, you know,
human trafficking, all of that. They were like, Oh,
I cannot put my name on that. And so yeah, in those everyone's like, Oh,
I cannot, like, I, I care about what you do, but like,
I can never like support you on this.
And they have no problem supporting like a lot of other causes.
And also though I work, I mean, my movie has been trying to make,
and other movies were being made already.
And this production companies gave him money.
And then as soon as they were like appreciated by like these other platforms,
they just drop the sponsorship and there's like, I can not show this movie.
And when you see, like, you know, there was the big controversy,
six or seven months ago with the NBA players that would in criticize China.
And yet they'll tell you how racist and everything else America is. It must,
it must just blow your mind.
I mean, but even though it blew my mind,
I couldn't speak out because I was scared. You know, like, they're gonna, what,
how am I gonna, like, I need to fight for my people.
What if all these countries, and I make me a CIS spy and blah, blah, blah,
you know, being a racist, all of that.
Like how do I even get a chance to fight for my people?
Maybe I still need to be like somehow being acceptable to them.
But like, and real, I was robbed in Chicago this year,
during the summer mast. And I was punched by these two black women.
And then in, and then I was trying to ask them like, can you, like,
I was asking people to have lunch too.
She was punching me and taking my wallet away. And these people were studying,
calling me a racist, like this, like middle of the Chicago, Michigan Avenue.
I still have a footage of the scars. And the second you are racist,
you're a bad person. While you're doing this, like color scheme,
doesn't make them fav. I was like, I mean, I have nanny was Muslim and he job,
like, I'm going to call her a person. Like, why would I do that?
And of course those girls worked.
If the police got the fridge over them using my credit card,
spending $3,000 at programming and like rooming there or something.
And I just couldn't believe like the people were seeing me this,
I was very petty. As you saw me,
this big three black women were like pushing me to the car and punching me.
And then district calling me a racist and like,
they're holding me down so they can run away so I can not call the police on
them. And that was like, Oh my gosh,
I cannot believe that I have a son in this country. Like,
this is not a safe country anymore. Like, things are not like,
okay anymore.
So what, what do you make about what's happening in the United States?
Cause one of the things we were talking about a couple of weeks ago is that the
chill around free speech that just people are, you said to me,
I think this is exactly what you said, but correct me if I'm wrong. I mean,
you said this is right now feeling like what it felt like.
I know this feeling.
I, before I say always,
I get like first thing my mom taught me was not even whisper because the first
and my school hear me in North Korea. And now I'm same thing.
Like trying to teaching my son. Like when you cross the, like, what, what grade?
And do you know, like crosswalk there's like white men,
like walking sign and he's like, we are, so of course he was like light color.
And man, like he says a white man, I can walk.
And people are looking at him as like, you can not say you're, I cannot,
I'm like always teaching him to be how not to be attacked. And like,
this is exactly my mom did to me. Like I just like,
and what also, what I see in America is that when I was going North Korea,
I was like third generation of this oppression.
I didn't even know what the alternative was like, but my grandmother knew,
like she was living under the Japanese colonization before Kim,
she lived her life and people at the time who knew what was different
existed, they stopped and they skip the silent.
And by the time when he came to us,
we didn't even know that we were slaves to Decatur. And that's what they say,
like why there's no revolution in North Korea. And I was like,
how do you fight when you don't know you're a slave.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about
international issues, instead of nonstop yelling out our international playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist they're all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.